hi thanks for having me congratulations
on the new cookbook tell us more about
the cookbook
yeah so it's called Comfort baking and
it comes out next week and there are
more than 100 recipes in the book from
breakfast through dessert all with the
name of comfort and mind and the idea is
that you can find comfort
uh relaxation what have you in the
entire process of baking from beginning
to end okay let's break this down water
give us some tips maybe three tips on on
how you can throw a great fall party
yeah so I think the idea behind the book
Comfort baking really applies to
entertaining as well we want it to be
just as enjoyable for the host as it is
for the guests and I think there's a few
easy ways we can do that my first uh tip
for that would be to make a head and
that applies to pretty much anything but
especially the food the great thing
about baked goods is that you can make a
lot of them a day two days even a week
in advance a lot of them actually taste
better if they sit for a day or two so
um and then if you're making something
Savory like a stew or a chili you can
chop up the veggies the day before
whatever you can do to just make the day
of that much easier and less stressful
how do you plan so nowadays so many
people have so many different allergies
how do you plan for someone who has
allergies and and certain reactions to
food yeah absolutely we have that in our
own household and I would say instead of
just asking each individual guests what
their preferences are what their
allergies are to consider I just have a
variety of foods available for everyone
um and you don't even have to make it
that complicated you can have a veggie
tray a bowl of fruit some cut up meat
cheeses that way people can kind of
build their own plates and everybody has
something that they can enjoy so you
have your food you're ready to go do you
put it all in the same spots you put in
the kitchen do you kind of spread it out
have some in the family room some in the
dining room or do you keep it in one
central location
I really like keeping it in one central
location it just keeps it really
stress-free that way I can see if
something needs to be refilled
um if a guest has a question about a
dish they know you know where the food
is where they can probably find me and
it's also a great place for guests that
if they don't know each other they can
meet at that that table they can talk
about the food and it's a great
conversation starter okay these are
amazing tips final question I I enjoy
cooking now and again but I hate doing
dishes what's the rule the person that
cooks doesn't have to do the dishes
right I agree that is the rule in our
house I'm never doing dishes I'm Gonna
Save this clip and show my wife look the
expert says whoever Cooks doesn't have
to clean Stephanie thank you so much for
joining us and again congratulations on
the new cookbook thank you in Las Vegas
now we